salut tout le monde
souhaite que je puisse être là avec vous
Je suis désolé lentement le bruit supplémentaire
comme vous pouvez le voir nous construisons le
dernier épisode de Mission Impossible
et en ce moment nous sommes au-dessus du magnifique vol
de Canyon et de la magnifique Afrique du Sud et
nous faisons  ce film pour le grand
écran pour que le public voie si vos
merveilleux théâtres
hey euh désolé de vous déranger Tom hey nous avons
tué
Chris McCoy salut tout le monde hey euh écoutez je
déteste interrompre mais euh nous devons vraiment
rouler nous perdons les lumières bas sur le
carburant oh  ouais nous devons rouler
ce n'est pas bon je suis désolé nous devons y aller
ouais attendez leur avez-vous parlé de la
chose oh ouais c'est une chose oh nous avons
nous avons un premier aperçu de la
bande-annonce de Mission Impossible
lors d'une projection très spéciale de Thompson
Maverick  dans son intégralité alors s'il vous plaît profitez d'
aujourd'hui
passons tous un bel été et action
voyons c'est un film
mal de
tout le monde pour les siècles à venir